keeping it real I think we should pray
for Trump what do you think 100% we
should pray Allah subhanAllah
the prophets Allah Islam prayed for Abu
jahil and Omar even a thought of you
allowed Allah and and we shall also pray
for Trump for every non-muslim we pray
along the LA we pray Allah Subhan Allah
guide them to your chosen path I would
not say convert them to Islam I would
say o Allah guide them to your chosen
path Almighty God guide them to the
chosen path thought and for me that
chosen path is Islam and I'm very sure I
really pray from my bottom of the heart
that oh Allah guide Trump to the chosen
path of Islam the path that Jesus
followed the path that Moses my peace be
upon him followed the path that all
prophets since the time of Adam a peace
be upon him followed till Jesus Christ
may peace be upon him and the same path
that prophet muhammad saw son came to
complete the teachings through the Quran
as a lot testifies in surah - or number
five at number three a glioma
a camel Tilikum vena cava at mom today
mati well at Monto alaikum name--it even
a D - lacrimal is Lama D now on this day
we have completed for you your religion
completed our favours upon you and
chosen for you Islam meaning the way of
peaceful submission as the way that
Allah will accept on day of judgment so
I truly pray for from for that we're
gonna let me get one more question in
and that just shows you I mean if if
where people have hate I mean why all
the love now because when you want the
best for someone look you pray for him
so we are people
given his great advice to the Muslims to
pray for this man that he does the right
things that he's just that he's fair
that God Almighty guides him and that's
out of the love
[Applause]